We see a lot of sort of figures and numbers
for kind of how small things are getting
in computing, right?
And I thought who better to come and talk to than Phil Moriarty, would you call yourself a nano-scientist?
h
Oh I guess I would it depends on which funding agency I'm applying to funding for, but yeah nano-scientist is a good one *laughs*
Yeah it's great to be back on Computerphile it's been a long time I don't know a couple of years or something like that?
Um.. So yeah we do, within the group here we manipulate individual atoms that's what we do
so we work at the level of not just single atoms and single molecules but actually looking inside single molecules
The state of the art is no longer, at least in the research and development community not in the commercial or industrial community
but in the research and development, particularly in the universities,
State of the art isn't seeing atoms we've been able to do that for years. In fact, we could see atoms as long ago as 1955.
Um, with something called the field ion microscope.
At the beginning of the 80s however,
it all changed because there was in instrument called the scanning tunneling microscope developed,
Which is basically a sharp probe, you bring it in close to a surface, you move it back and forth
and you measure a force or an interaction
and the important thing is if you can make this probe atomically sharp, then your resolution is at the single atom level.
So we can see atoms we can move them, but as I said the state of the art is actually single bonds
looking at single electron orbitals, single chemical bonds, and manipulating those.
Commercially, that technology doesn't exist and its gonna be quite a while before we get down to devices which are truly mass produced at the single atom level.
But if you look at the, you  know, from the 70s I think we were at the sort of 10 micrometer level,
so 10 micrometers, a micrometer is a thousandth of a millimeter, a millionth of a meter.
We are now at the 14 nano-meter level, so the really offhand way to try and get some vague handle on it,
is, for many of you out there perhaps not for me but for many of you out there- your hair will grow roughly about a nano-meter a second,
Particularly if you're in your, you know, teens, 20s
Your hair's growing out at about that rate of about a nano-meter a second.
In the context of single atoms, the diameter of an atom is about a few tenths of a nano-meter
When we're working at 14 nano-meters and the feature sizes on semiconductor chips are around about 14 nano-meters
We're talking, you know, tens of atoms, we're talking about about 50-60 atoms wide, the features
So it's um, it's really quite remarkable you know?
We went from a thousandth of a millimeter down to 50 atoms in the course of, you know, 50 years or something like that
So you mentioned the features, is that things like the individual wires that go to make a transistor?
Yeah, exactly, that's exactly, so it's the feature size really is to do with the
all the different elements on the chip in terms, largely the transistors and the wiring and the different types of components you have in the chip
that have been just scaled all the way down to that level.
At the moment, the way it works and the way it worked for decades is that you control where the electrons are, you control the electron's charge
and electrons will respond to electric fields so if you've got a battery, and you've got two metal plates and you put a battery across them
What you have between those plates is whats called an electric field
if you put an electron in there, then that electron will respond to the electric field
A great deal of the electronics around us is based on silicon, there are other compounds, like Gallium arsenide for example
But a great deal of the micro and the nano electronics industry is based on silicon.
S: So does the silicon work a bit like the plastic, or maybe the PCB, if I said the green PCB, that's plastic with wires on it-
That's a really good question, no the silicon's much more active than that, much more active, it's not like you pattern these features in the silicon
as just a passive substrate, you're actually using the silicon and the electrons in the silicon and you're controlling where the electrons in the silicon go
and you can take the raw silicon and you can dope it, you can add impurities deliberately
to add, to introduce more electrons, or indeed, actually, to take electrons out.
So we got electrons and holes. And that means you can change dramatically how when you put a battery on this thing, or when you put a power source on it
how those electrons flow, and then by, in turn, patterning little metal features on top of that, you can apply electric fields and you can control where the electrons go.
You generally switch on or switch off the flow of the electrons, you trap the electrons in a region of space.
Now, the problem with this technology is that it's starting to run out of steam.
It's been running out of steam for quite some time.
And there's been lot's of nay-saying going on since the early 80s
Saying it's going to stop -it's going to fail
and the semiconductor industry
is extremely clever and comes up with new ideas time and time again.
But, you can't beat physics
and were going to come very soon -we're now at tens of atoms
when we get down to features that are just a few atoms, or say ten atoms across
then, we've got to take into account that
once you get down to that level
it's quantum, which means that you can no longer just think of the electron as a little hard
billiard ball, which is the picture that all of us have in our heads
it's actually got a wave-like character
which is not to say it would be easy if it were just that the electrons spread out in space
that's not what happens
it means that under certain circumstances it behaves
as if it were a wave
and if you find that confusing
good,
because so many of us find it confusing.
This is raw quantum physics
As a physicist, it's not that you understand it.
You just get used to it.
Once you get down to this level
you get this wave-like characteristic
and just like waves will spread out
so you might want to trap the electron in this region of space
but it's starting now -due to this really small size-
at the point where we've got to take that wave-like nature into consideration
and the electron could spread out.
We call that tunneling.
And that means you want to trap it in space, but in fact
you just can't. It's so slippery, it's tunneling away.
So I'm gonna find a really stupid question cause I am full of them today
I've heard that quantum computing is a good thing, so I mean...
Oh,   So, oh, so, no, So there's a different, yeah right, *bleargh*
So there's quantum computing which is where you absolutely exploit that. So there is classical computing which is what we have now.
And than we have quantum computing. Now those are two very, very different paradigms.
So instead this is quantum effects on classic computing
Perfect! Yes. Quantum effects on classical computing instead of just being pure quantum,
The sort of mindset in the industry and the mindset in some areas of academia  is
How do we work around these effects? I think we are gonna have to start, particularly when we get down to these really small sizes
We are gonna have to stop seeing them as something that's a, erm, you know to the detriment of device and exploit it instead
Well we can do amazing things when we start thinking of that wave-like character
And the move towards a much more quantum mindset
Where instead of trying to work around these things, we exploit them
So we work with silicon a great deal in the lab
It's quite shiny...
It is very very shiny. So, it's polished on that side.
So, when we do our experiments to manipulate atoms
we take a chunk of this, a little bit less than a centimeter squared, something like that
we put it in a ultrahigh vacuum and we heat it up to about 1200C
and that drives off the oxide that is on the surface
and just after it cools down, we can see atoms.
So it's actually straight forward to see individual atoms on Silicon surfaces.
That's not how the semiconductor industry works because to see individual atoms, particularly the way we do it
and the way many other groups in the world do it
it takes many hours to get good images
To form the components and pattern the wafer, you use something called photolithography
or something called electron beam lithography
and photolithography has been the standard throughout the industry for very verry many years
but it is, again, running out of steam.
So you take the wafer, you coat it with a thin film of polymer or plastic
and then you put what is called a mask in front of it
or stencil basically. And then you shine light through that stencil
and then you expose the plastic at the surface in particular regions according to the pattern
and the important this is when this particular polymer is exposed to light, it becomes soluable
The regions that aren't exposed aren't soluable so then you can put it in an etch
and you can remove those regions where it's soluble and leave those regions where it's unsoluable
That's the fundamental process, that's the fundamental process in a nutshell
And do they do different layers of this as well?
So, it's extremely clever because you're limited by the natural wavelength of light
light has a wavelength and therefore that wavelength ultimately determines the feature size
and with the current processing which is about 14 nano-meters, they do something really really clever which is
they use one mask, expose, and then they put another mask and just offset it a little bit
which is really clever
and given this is 14nano-meters, when I say little bit, that's a tincy tiny bit
and actually getting those in registry is quite tricky
So, that's where the industry is at the moment
To go beyond that, really to get down to these features which are 10 atoms or a few atoms across
then you have to start thinking about lots of other issues and lots of other approaches
One way of doing that is to move to a much shorter wavelength
a much shorter wavelength means much higher energy
and we have something called Extreme Ultraviolet so that's far off the end of the Ultraviolet range
And you can get down to -or the standard they're aiming for is 13.5nm wavelength light
and that's quite high in energy. It's really high in energy
and that will enable you to get the feature size much much smaller
You can really push the resolution, you can really push the feature size down by using
instead of photons of light, using electrons
and you can squeeze the wavelength of electrons down much much smaller
the problem with that is it's a serial -with light you have your sample,
you have your wafer and you just bathe it in light
with electrons, it's a raster beam
which means it is, instead of a parallel process, it's a serial process
which means it's incredibly slow
So electron beam gives you much better definition and much better resolution
but for the semiconductor industry, it's a real pain because it's so unbelievably slow
So... And for us, when we manipulate atoms
it's exactly the same process
we use a single probe, we bring it in close to a surface so we can see atoms
and we can manipulate those atoms and move them around, but it's excruciatingly slow because it's a serial process
This is the crystal structure of silicon. Just assume all the atoms are the same color
but each sphere here, each ball, represents a single silicon atom
and the silicon crystallizes in a form where you have these tetrahedrons
so if you take one silicon atom here, this purple one. It is connected to 1, 2, 3, 4.
and that's because in chemical terms, silicon has four valence electrons
It wants to form four valance bonds
We have these, really silly at times, frustrating; this is chemistry, this is physics. It's all part of one integrated hole
even computer science is part of that integrated hole, sometimes.
...but that's sort of off the point of what we were discussing
It's fun, but just to show you in action that um...